l'océan et le monde de tous les mystères
les humains connaissent mieux la surface
de Mars que le font des mers quant aux
créatures aquatiques qui vivent même
celles que tu as pu imaginer et bien
tout était faux
prenons la puissance grand raquette le
monde sera soit fait de sang qui coule
les navires mais tout sort cette
histoire
les Kraken sont des créatures
majestueuses de noble protecteur je suis
juste Rubik's
des générations entières de Kraken ont
protégé les mers de la créature la plus
dangereuse la plus ça soit fait de
pouvoir qu'il soit les sirènes
oui la sirène mais tout le monde aime
les sirènes
[Applaudissements]
moi c'est Chelsea les sirènes sont
égoïste prétentieuses narcissique
les pires de tout qu'est-ce qui se passe
tout va bien je connais ton secret tu es
une Kraken cachée sous forme humaine il
faut que je rentre maintenant et bientôt
tout le monde connaîtra la vérité bisous
es-tu prête à affronter ton destin je
vais juste vivre ma vie
tu as des pouvoirs que tu n'imagines
même pas il est temps rubis
je veux plus me cacher plus jamais
grand-maman oui je vais apprendre à
utiliser mes pouvoirs
camouflage super vitesse
carapace voyons de quoi tu es capable
oui et c'est pas de la rigolade
[Musique]
quel que soit le défi une Kraken répond
toujours à la pelle
de voir plus grand